integrantes del movimiento ius for
claimat friends expresaron su
indignación por el estado de deterioro
actual del medio ambiente y las acciones
del ejecutivo francés que a su juicio no
están a la altura de la gravedad de la
situación aquí en la llamada Academia
del clima los jóvenes lamentaron que
Francia acaba de vivir el segundo verano
más caliente registrado jamás tres horas
de calor temperaturas superiores a 40
grados y pronósticos nada alentadores
para los próximos años señalaron también
los incendios forestales de este periodo
estival que devastaron 65.000 hectáreas
seis veces el tamaño de París actúa
ahora o nada después se leía en uno de
los carteles en la ciudad de lille En
referencia a las lluvias e inundaciones
de Francia cuyas pérdidas materiales en
los últimos 38 años sobrepasan los
21.000 millones de euros y sigue en
aumento otro grupo de jóvenes bloqueó
una de las terminales del aeropuerto de
vuelos privados de burges cerca de París
para denunciar los Ultra uno de los
principales responsables de la crisis
climática según ellos allí criticaron la
hipocresía del gobierno que pide a los
ciudadanos comunes a ahorrar
electricidad Pero permite a los
millonarios emisiones extraordinarias de
gases contaminantes cada vez que despega
un jet privado en la jornada también se
ha hecho énfasis en la educación con
propuestas de insertar lecciones de
cuidado del medio ambiente en la
educación preescolar y no reservar las
únicamente a otros niveles de enseñanza